c'è nessuno
nel mittente c'è scritto caro murray o
donna romangolo nook è raro sembra ci fu
una lingua straniera
io penso di avere una figura piccola
matita mente spiaggia dicendo un berlino
poverini non mai
poi la prendo io questa bambola
[Musica]
se stai facendo
sto cercando una cosa che cosa eccola la
camera
[Musica]
che ti serve una camera per dimostrarti
che slutty si muove ancora con questa
storia di slavi che si muove il mero
slavi per tutto il giorno magari anche
tutta la notte
così vedrai che realmente si muove
mi sembra un'ottima idea è come detto tu
lasciamolo acceso anche di notte così
finalmente scopriremo chi è che mi ruba
il cibo no ma non penso che la pt ruby
il cibo la notte secondo te allora chi e
come lo ruba e sarai tu a mangiarlo
durante la notte no no no vabbè comunque
inizio ad azionare la camera e vedrai
vedrai che ho ragione
ok
[Musica]
ma fammi capire l'intenzione di rimanere
qui tutto il giorno a fissare la bambola
se necessario si anche se c'è la
videocamera voglio vederla quando si
muove voglio vedere se parla e dice
qualcosa di strano almeno ai due prove
alla tua prova visiva più quella film
alla brava siccome mi cretino o anche il
pd ma io adesso devo uscire no non puoi
lasciarmi sola con frattini mi fa paura
è che problema c'è lo porterò con me
metti un bagagliaio se ne sta tranquillo
in effetti sesta ci sono un bagagliaio
non dovrebbe crearsi nessun problema ma
lo metto in bagagliaio così almeno fa
compagnia la ruota di scorta no ok va
bene sicuramente sarò più tranquilla se
lo porti con te
prendi il oppure va bene eccoci qua
slutty siamo molti è riuscito insieme
siccome rossi usciamo insieme non vedo
l'ora di fare un bel giro in macchina
accomodato nel bellissimo posto del
bagagliaio
però ti preoccupare al mio nome di un po
d'aria fai un bel giretto pronti sin
dalla bruttezza in ogni traccia ok ciao
[Musica]
sì
allora qua plate abbiamo per te proprio
il posto ok allora di mento quaggiù snap
[Musica]
così stai comodo
arrivando al momento
a berlino al vero siamo rimasti io e te
ci facciamo compagnia
[Musica]
siamo un pochino giocare andiamo
beh
[Musica]
un teatrino
sia i fan di esservi liberati di me non
è possibile
sto sognando non sono un sogno sono un
incubo
[Risate]
[Musica]
stai forze cercando questo è fermo
dovuto ritirare centro a partecipare ad
un mio spettacolo dei drive sarà
divertentissimo ricche di comoda dei pop
corn se una volta un pupazzo bambola o
pur artino come volete chiamarlo insomma
di homs la psp era molto felice quando
veniva riportato in vita che poteva
finalmente continuare la sua missione
missione è un segmento di creato per chi
avesse parlare perché sei stato spedito
qui troppe domande mia cara rita meglio
che tu non sappia che mi ha creato e
spedito qui mi dispiace per te
ap questa videocamera stava registrando
per tutto il tempo
ora voglio e provveda mostrare a tutti i
papà non ti crederà nessuno comunque e
in più non ti piacerebbe diventando un
burattino come me no non voglio
diventare un burattino come che potremmo
fare tanti spettacoli assieme e se lo
impone attivo e divertentissimo sai ma
la cosa noiosa e fare di spettacoli da
solo ho bisogno di un'altra burattino
che mi faccia compagnia e io oltre ad
essere un burattino ha un grande potere
posso trasformare le persone in
volantini non è fantastico
[Musica]
sei pronto a diventare un burattino
bomber
[Applauso]
a
unità
tutto bene
sì
[Musica]